[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde
avant de commencer la chaire de données
avait posé une question avant avant de
poser cette question
je recommande de ville de matane où la
terre contre lui excelle comme ça c'est
mieux
la conférence d'aujourd'hui s'intitule
est ce que le bonheur existe
je vais d'abord parmi vous je voudrais
vous poser la question qui s'est déjà
posé la question est ce que le bonheur
existe les flammes à hockey qui pense
que le bonheur n'existe pas et quoi
qu'en face il y aura toujours quelque
chose pour nous rendre malheureux qui
pense à un examen hockey qui pose que le
bonheur existe qui a des trucs qu'on
peut faire pour
y accéder dès techniques lever la main à
dire ce qui optimise super vous pouvez
vous applaudir donc là on va simplifier
les choses
donc je veux que la conférence ne soient
adressés
vous pouvez tous le voit revêtu ce
montant ok donc la question que je vous
pose aujourd'hui pour recadrer les
choses ne pas partir dans tous les sens
c'est par rapport à votre carrière
par rapport à vos études qui parmi vos
pense qu'on doit suivre ce que la
société demande ce que les parents
demandent ce que l'environnement
extérieur demande qui pensent que dont
les hits feu et dans la vie de manière
générale on doit suivre ça les flamands
hockey qui d'un autre côté panse que
[Musique]
on doit plutôt écouté son coeur plutôt
écouter sa passion et faire seulement ça
qu'ils pensent aller là bas
ok là je les revends tir brièvement sur
mon histoire juste pour arriver à une
idée à une conclusion que je vois que
vous fassiez aujourd'hui donc quand j'ai
fait mon voyage en inde pour me former
au yoga et au yoga du rire comment va la
chance d'expérimenter ça après nous
consulter mon voyage
si j'avais su plier ma passion si vous
avez suivi mon coeur je ne serai pas
aujourd'hui devant vous je serais restée
en inde pour continuer de rester là bas
en même temps si j'avais écouté ce que
la société ce que l'environnement
extérieur demande
je ne serais jamais parti en inde et je
serais resté à travailler dans une
multinationale de 8 heures à 18 heures
en tant qu'ingénieur et je ne serais pas
dans plus ici à faire la conférence
aujourd'hui nous cli des clés que je
veux qu'on atteigne aujourd'hui ensemble
ces vies des déconvenues
est ce que vous êtes en train de me suis
levé la main si vous êtes en train de me
suis occupé d'autres
aujourd'hui l'idée que je veux vous
transmettre ces je ne vous dis pas je ne
vous demande pas de laisser la société
deux côtés de laisser ce que demande de
l'environnement à l'extérieur de côté et
de suivre juste votre passion je ne dis
pas ne suivait pas votre passion je dis
simplement
ne laissez pas les contraintes
complètement de connu en même temps en
suivant
en prenant en considération les
contraintes extérieures l'idée aussi
c'est de ne pas oublier sa passion
oubliez ce que le coeur de monde pour
rendre les choses plus faciles et de
compréhension
je voudrais vous poser une question qui
est les etats-unis et pense que c'est
cool d'être là bas les flamands ok
d'accord maintenant qu'ils aimeraient
soit faire des études là-bas dans une
université prestigieuse soit vivre la
barre pendant un moment les blâmes ah ok
donc maintenant en prenant en compte que
le fait de d'étudier une année là bas ça
peut coûter entre 30 mille quarante
mille voire même plus de dollars qui
aujourd'hui a les moyens de se payer des
études là-bas les blocs auquel et à tous
ceux d'aubin donc vous voyez bien que ce
n'est pas quelque chose de forcément
réalisable
maintenant je vous pose la question de
l'autre côté quai les moyens qui peut
souffler s'inscrire dans un courant dean
gratuit sur easy ex ou bien un bouddha
city pour acquérir de nouvelles
compétences développées quelque chose
qu'il aime qui peut faire ça les blâmant
voilà donc là on commence à converger un
peu dandy des compromis c'est si je ne
peux pas faire quelque chose aujourd'hui
que moi je le veux il ya toujours un
moyen d'y accéder
autrement donc et je vais rebondir a
sûrement l'histoire donc je rebondis sur
mon histoire
aujourd'hui en étant ingénieur
informatique
quand j'ai commencé à travailler il y
avait un petit quelque chose qui
manquait je ne pouvais pas impacter le
monde
chaque matin je me réveille quand je
vais à l'entreprise
faisais mon travail de huit heures
quelquefois de 9h quelquefois de 10
heures en une journée
quelquefois plus je sentais qu'il y
avait un truc qui moquaient que voilà
j'avais qui a le rêve de 1,2 changement
faire quelque chose ce qui laisse un bac
développement allez-y je veux voir des
brasseries c'est le voilà donc en
faisant mon travail je sentais pas que
je faisait bouger le mans et c'est pour
ça que j'ai décidé de partir en inde
pour me former au yoga en même temps en
faisant le travail de prof de yoga nous
arriver devant une personne que je lui
disais voilà bonjour je suis prof de
yoga en me disait toujours vous me posez
toujours la question de l'autre côté
et à part le yoga fait quoi dans la vie
donc le yoga n'était jamais perçu comme
un métier un travail c'était juste voilà
tu fais du yoga ok on connais tu fais
quoi
de l'autre côté et donc l'idée c'est que
avec le compromis
j'ai gardé métier d'ingénieur j'ai gardé
le travail d'ingénieur et à côté j'ai
commencé à voir à développer le yoga
yoga dionne et aujourd'hui je ne mène
pas la vie la plus facile ce n'est pas
toujours facile d'avoir de métier en
même temps mais j'ai lavé la plus
satisfaisante
si vous passez un jour devant le
parcours de santé mazarin c'est une
preuve sur scène
si vous passez à 7 heures du matin vous
allez sûrement trouvé un groupe de
personnes en train de rire il faut
juste comme ça sans raison et c'est moi
qui écris c'est le gâteau et aussi si si
vous passez par hasard dont l'une des
plus grandes salles de sport en tunisie
vous allez retrouver dispenser des cours
de yoga
donc aujourd'hui je me retrouve à vivre
une vie où je n'attends pas jusqu'à ce
que le travail parce je n'attends pas
jusqu'à arriver à vendredi
je n'attends pas jusqu'à arriver aux
vacances de l'été pour vivre pour
profiter chaque jour pour moi et une
occasion extraordinaire de contribuer
dans les vidéos est en fait la chose à
laquelle je voudrais arriver c'est par
rapport à vous la philosophie à adopter
pour créer de votre côté une vie de la
cades vous serez satisfaits pervis qui
vous donnera du plaisir de la joie et du
bonheur qui a envie de sentir qu'ils
s'amusent chaque jour qui me passe un
bon moment les verts ale
ok non l'idée en fait pour créer cette
vie il ya deux éléments qui sont
nécessaires vous me suivez
vous vous êtes pas endormi ok donc il ya
combien d'éléments j'ai dit deux
éléments voilà le premier élément c'est
la conscience de l'être
c'est quoi le premier élément ça paraît
un peu du charabia
nous on va explorer ça ensemble le
deuxième élément c'est la joie de vivre
c'est quoi le deuxième élément oil la
conscience de l'être
mais la joie de vie avant 2 avant
d'explorer sa avec plus de profondeur
je vais vous inviter à vivre une
expérience pour ressentir les choses
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas juste parler
je voudrais que vous ressentez les
choses d'autres d'abord asseyez-vous
d'une manière confortable
voilà chez les jambes relâcher les bras
le christ ne croisait pas les bras ne
croisez pas les jambes relâcher votre
gorge essayé de reculer le bassin pour
avoir le dos de voix dans la limite du
possible
voilà maintenant je vais vous demander
juste pendant une minute
une huile de votre dans le restant
silencieux juste une minute de votre
temps et pendant 7 minutes c'est pas
celle c'est juste la mélodie par
habitude je voudrais aussi que vous
l'utilisez pas de smartphone juste
pendant une minute
voilà les pendant sept minutes
je voudrais vous guider dans une
expérience l'expérience elle est simple
vous allez fermer les yeux
ça va prendre deux minutes et en fermant
les yeux
je voudrais que vous vous concentrez sur
les mots l'extérieur bonne conscience du
bruit de la ventilation fallu conscience
lui 102 me vois tout en gardant les yeux
formule prennent conscience des villes
x2
vers 12h10 permet de rester concentré
prenez conscience de la température de
la salle sans émettre de jugement du
juste prix majeurs prenez conscience du
contact de votre corps lachaise
si c'est impossible de fermer les yeux
fixés un point idéalement les yeux sont
fait résister à l envie de bouger
autorisez-vous l'escarène
prenez conscience du bois de votre coach
national
tout en continuant de prendre conscience
de l'extérieur une partie de l'eau va se
centrer sur la respiration
vous inspirez pleinement avec nous le
dira
les mains de dieu en inspirant le sait
le ventre selon l'une des dix pires en
les inhumant dessous les champs pendant
10 secondes qui est vidé la tête restée
seulement des gouttes respiration en
relâchant les éboulis drogue centre il
sur la relaxation de sur la respiration
doucement doucement lever les douanes
doucement doucement de boucher les
artères
et vous où les yeux
qui se sent plus léger les bienvenus
ok ya ceux qui ont perdu du poids c'est
le qui sent la tête plus légères lève la
bombe qui sont plus de calme à
l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
quelle que soit la décision que vous
devez prendre dans votre vie quelle que
soit la situation dans laquelle vous
êtes il explique vous est toujours
possible de fermer les yeux
le créer le vide intérieur et de juste
centré sur votre respiration et là vous
êtes dans la conscience d'eux
vous comprenez que le monde extérieur
n'est qu'un décor et qu'avec votre
respiration
vous pouvez vous recentrer sur vous-même
et écouter le silence qui existent à
l'intérieur de vos et là c'est l'une des
conditions pour être heureux si vous
n'arrivez pas à distinguer entre ce qui
existe à l'extérieur parce qu'ils
existent à l'intérieur ne pourrait
jamais être heureux et si vous arrivez à
créer cette barre énergétique à faire la
distinction entre ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur dans votre jeu est ce que
vous êtes vous à l'intérieur si vous
arrivez à créer cette barrière vous
pouvez cultiver des moments de joie en
attendant la bouse et un bleu l'objectif
aussi ce n'est pas de dormir
le cyclisme a pas de données d'accord
donc maintenant je vais vous inviter à
vous lever tous à les élever
donc on a parlé de la conscience de
l'être
on n'a pas besoin d'être en même temps
trop sérieux trop axé sur la respiration
toujours les yeux fermés non je ne vous
demande pas ça je vous demande si de
bouger de cultiver la joue à l'intérieur
on pourra applaudir tous ensemble alizée
applaudi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez-y
semaine
arrêtez de vous rendre à se synchroniser
tous ensemble avec le même rythme on va
faire tous ensemble un deux de trois
tous ensemble et c'est super maintenant
on va ajouter plus de mouvement va
applaudir une fois à droite une fois à
gauche on va faire en veut aller du tout
en maintenant on va aller plus loin on
va créer on va cultiver la joie raconte
yves et le rire d'autres lieux de titres
un deux de trois
on va dire dans son regard des oies ou
vos allées du tout 500 euros
oh
non
nouveau
qui se sent bien les blâmant qui se sont
joyeux de l'intérieur qui sent plus de
mouvements plus d'euphorie plus de
légèreté
[Applaudissements]
donc le bonheur c'est aussi ça une fois
vous arrivez à créer cet état de vie une
fois vous arrivez à créer cette barrière
energy team entre le monde qui nous
entoure et boul
c'est aussi sympa du sustt vous lâcher
est ce que est ce que je vous donne je
vous ai donné une raison pour être
heureux là maintenant est-ce que vous
avez plutôt cultivé la joie sans réseau
et donc en prenant conscience
ces deux éléments le premier c'est la
conscience de n'être et le deuxième
c'est la joie intérieure
vous créez ce set
ressourcement antérieures qui vous
permet de trouver toutes les solutions
qui peuvent vous aider dans votre ville
en particulier la notion de coop robin
est maintenant pour être plus concret
encore plus l'idée ce n'est pas juste de
fermer les yeux de respirer et de faire
vos achats ont guidé c'est de passer à
l'action
c'est ce que je vous demande aujourd'hui
je vous demande de passer à l'action
donc s'il ya quelque chose qui vous
dérange quelque chose que vous n'aimez
pas dans votre vie est ce que vous allez
rester les bras baissés à ne rien faire
d'accord donc l'idée c'est de passer à
l'action
et pour passer à l'action des fois il ya
des choses qu'on peut faire concrètement
et des fois il n'y a pas de choses à
faire et moi je n'y a pas de choses à
faire dans le coma parce que là
certaines circonstances qui vont vous
empêcher d'agir et moi ce que je vous de
vente à ce moment c'est de ces deux
distinguer entre la résignation et de
lâcher prise qui a déjà entendu parler
de la notion de lâcher prise des blâmes
ah ok no qui a déjà entendu une personne
dire y'en a ras le bol et gabe et cas
par jour
beckham ac tous levé la main qui a déjà
entendu ça non sans mal voilà donc vidé
ce n'est pas d'être dans la résignation
de ceux d'hier allard albert duquesne au
foot je ne peux pas changer les choses
l'idée c'est d'être dans le lâcher prise
c'est à ce moment là je n'arrive pas à
changer les choses si je garde une
attitude neutre positive
les circonstances pour en changer et je
pourrais faire quelque chose et je
reviens toujours sur la notion de
compromis
si aujourd'hui je ne peux pas changer
les choses complètement l'a sûrement un
petit pas quelque chose avec lequel je
peux commencer pour changer les choses
et je voudrais conclure avec une petite
histoire c'est un grand père qui ya plus
de 90 ans et ce grand-père n'arrivais
plus à marcher sur les pieds parce que
son corps affaibli et l'a fait une chute
grave sur la tête et il commençait à
déprimer à force d'être assise et une
fois toute la famille s'est réunie le
père le fils et le grand père et le fils
voyez le grand-père qui n'arrivait plus
à marcher il voyait le grand-père qui
commençait à déprimer et et lui dit
qu'est ce qui se passe
il dit que je n'arrive plus à marcher
lui dit tiens on va essayer et lui prend
la main et le grand père lui dit ménage
ça y est je n'arrive plus à marcher j'ai
des problèmes aux anges c'est
physiquement à pau c est le petit fils
luigi tiens on va essayer il le prend
par la main il lève le grand père se met
debout sur les pieds et ensuite le petit
fils lui tire la main et le le grand
père commence à vous